a new show on abc tonight from uh the
creator
of uh a big little lies and so much more
he
is david e kelly he's been uh the king
of television for so for a long time
um it airs tonight 10 eastern on abc
every tuesday night from uh here on out
and it's called big sky
and uh it's about um from what i'm
understanding well
i don't wanna front load it too much so
i'll ask my next guest if it is in fact
what you look up at uh after the latest
philadelphia eagles uh
game uh does not go your way and you're
staring and looking at something trying
to
think of something beautiful ryan
phillippi joining me here on the show is
that what it's about ryan
my friend who i haven't spoken to in so
long wants to start off
the conversation by just punching a gun
no it's it's been a year of frustration
and futility
among the many things that i've missed
now from a societal sense
when the eagles actually used to put
together a credible football team
um this game against the giants you know
the lead up to it was
lane johnson's coming back we got al
shawn jeffrey on the field our first
round pick jalen reagers
they looked abysmal just flat and
and as an avid football watcher and fan
you can't there are certain irrefutable
fundamental things that if they are not
fixed you will not improve
and i see too many of those to like
allow myself to be affected emotionally
at this point see this is the way i
wanted to start it ryan just to mix
things up and say hello by the way
um yeah hello yeah hello um but also
because i know
you're you're probably doing uh a lot of
interviews or tours to promote big sky
and
yeah you can't really get your uh
something off your chest about
wentz with you know access hollywood and
things like that
and also it's let's be honest it's fun
for both you and your audience to hear
a miserable fan of another franchise we
won't even get into the jets
oh gosh i think the whole team has mono
this season
well um well here well
that's for sure um and it's under the w
column unfortunately
or as i said before we're we've come so
far
we've come so far but we're also that
much closer to trevor lawrence
that much closer yeah gotta complete the
job gotta finish the job
and i think and i think they are ryan
with the with the uh
the well sam's gonna give it a whirl no
well we're just gonna keep him out we
wanna make sure he's 100 healthy before
he returns and hopefully
he will not be 100 healthy for his sake
and for the the sake of the franchise
in my estimation and i feel horrible
saying that i feel horrible saying that
but it's true
i have arrived at the thank god for
fantasy football portion of my season
um you know i still have moderate
success in that realm
i went three and i have three teams i
went three and o this weekend so i'm
gonna ride that high
well before we get to that though uh
ryan phillippe here on the rich hissing
show let's not give up hope here because
as you know uh in from sure uh having
uh purchased houses and rented places in
your entire life
of being an actor um real estate is all
about location and
and the location that the eagles are in
is first place and the nfc east
is first place so there's not even party
like as you know when you're it's
gearing up philadelphia at cleveland
this coming week that
this may be the moment where it actually
does turn
and they actually start playing like a
division leader you don't think
there's not even that part of you hey at
some point
someone's going to win the ugliest day
contest that's for sure
you know somebody's got to come out of
that trash heap
and i guess represent the division but
you know i i don't know i just i'm so
frustrated i think the giants are
looking good i think that yes
the way they move the ball and they've
got some young defensive players that
are starting to
emerge uh you know i don't think that uh
it's a it's a direct path for the eagles
especially after
what i've been seeing lately so i mean
uh where do you stand in terms of
uh the hot topic for philadelphia eagles
fans i've had
uh several call in about at least given
jalen hurts a world
what's your two cents on that i think
the offense needs a shot in the arm i
think the team in general needs a little
bit of a wake up and i think you see
that sometimes whether it's a
a a definite and a change going forward
maybe it's that spark that lights a fire
under certain parts of
the of the team that are dormant right
now um
you know look at the guy's a winner look
what he did in college look at the
heisman look at
you know i'd like to see what he can do
athletically instead of these little
you know two three four plays a game
which is a lot of pressure to put on a
rookie like you know i'll just thrust
you in on this on
in this series i'd like to see him have
control for a few
i guess so you know the the problem is
is what happens if he's
successful yeah you know
because wence is paid so much that's
kind of the issue
once you open that genie from the bot i
guess it won't matter if you're winning
games
i guess it won't matter no it won't but
there are some hefty
uh financial considerations to be paid
sure
what did you did you see foals last
night too i mean that's got to hurt you
too somebody who must love the guy for
various reasons and obvious reasons but
that was pretty brutal last night
you know yeah yeah i mean it's it's
definitely not working out for him up
there
you know and every philly fan wants the
best for foals we were even dreaming of
a potential playoff matchup with the
bears and eagles and having wentz versus
fold i do not think that's in the cards
for so what about your fantasy team
let's hit that ryan
what do you got for um i've got three i
have one uh with my delaware guys i grew
up with i've got an
la league that has some crazies in it
like bob menory
is in that one and he's actually awful
he's awful i don't think he has a win
this season please hold on a second
memory is the jets of your fantasy
football
is that what you're saying me you can
quote me on that
yeah i mean i i i would i would i would
use the
four letters uh an acronym that he uses
on his show but even that might be too
racy for for this that's what he is of
his fantasy league
he is yeah yeah
i mean like it's like i play him this
coming week and i just know it's an
automatic win
he's had saquon barkley in the entire
season he's just an idiot wait a minute
he doesn't oh hold on a second
bob menory is one of those guys in the
fantasy league that doesn't even
touch his lineup is that what you're
saying i mean in this
particular league yes that is the case
that is 100
the case oh my word
you got to get at him i think we are
right now to be honest with you ryan
okay so you're you've got to win in that
league coming up this week
um and then so you're delaware boys i
love that so you're still tight with the
the people you grew up with back in the
day yeah yesterday
my best friend from high school or two
of my best two or three of my best
friends from high school and this other
kid i've known since fifth grade and
and yeah and so i'm in a league with all
of them and when they brought me in they
thought i was gonna be a patsy
you know the la guy hollywood's not
gonna know his sports and
you know they're all you know
contractors and you know blue collar
jobs and
i've won the league uh you know three
out of the last five years look at you
you elitist you so who's the third
what's the third league that you're in
what's the third league of the colorado
league so my assistant
is from colorado and they they somebody
dropped out
and he uh asked me to become a part of
that okay
all right i'm in contention in all three
which is that's hard that's not hard to
do i'm in playoff
i'm in the pit playoff picture in all
three okay so i'm gonna put you on the
spot ryan because i'm in the multiple
leagues as well and there's one that i
want to win more than the other
um which is the one that you want to win
more than any of them
the delaware one okay yeah back home
and what are your team names what are
your team names um
one of them is the kovid 16. okay
okay one of them one of them is called
bench points because
years ago i tied with a guy and then
then looked and i then i had an l and
i'm like i asked the commissioner why
did i have an l
and he goes because we went to bench
point i'm like what the you can't
that's weird you know you just break the
bench's strategy you can't
you can't penalize me for the bet
excellent uh that's an excellent way of
protesting and then the third one is
what
the third one is damn it i'll have to
look it up
see that's the league you don't want to
win i understand we've come up we've
come up with some new
neat ones lately uh the last one was uh
cam's
suede fez right chris that's the one we
came up with recently because he showed
up with his
yeah cam suede yeah he showed up with a
suede fez
after the game this week and did that
hail mary the hail murray affect you in
any way
this past week yeah because i have uh
kyler he starts me and one of my
he's amazing what a fantasy player he is
what an absolutely
third team's name is the pounding you
know jesse ventura the wrestler
of course the mind the pounding the
pounding
there's this sound bite of him saying
the pounding and so that's one of my
other teammates
ryan phillippe here on the rich eisen
show okay now let's get to what big sky
really is about yes sir um i i give you
the floor cause it looks
awful juicy um the promos have been all
over monday night football
um and abc it debuts tonight at 10
eastern time i give you the floor
on it yeah after your favorite show the
bachelorette it comes on hey that's
brockman that's brockman that's his
guilty pleasure i'm all over it he's all
over it
i've been seeing your promos for two
months and i'm so in on this
guy so it's it's an awesome show in all
honesty david e kelly his track record
speaks for itself pick offenses ali
mcfeel big little lies all of that but
this
is sort of new territory for him because
it's a mystery
thriller it's each episode's going to
end in a cliffhanger
it's got twists and turns not typically
expected
of network television tremendous cast
really really awesome uh writing and
and and this and montana itself becomes
a character within the show the notion
of
these wide open spaces where anything
can be lurking and
um at the outset my character is trying
to find out what's happened to these two
girls that have gone missing
my son's girlfriend never shows up and
so i go
out looking for them and along with my
uh estranged ex-wife and current
girlfriend we're going to try to uncover
this potential tracking
situation our trafficking situation it
does look a little bit
just based on the uh on the promos a
little twin peaks-ish
a little bit would you agree with that
absolutely it's got
elements of dark humor and and that
quirkiness that you
that you can relate to like david lynch
it's cool to see
uh davide kelly go that direction
you know what i i mean talk about being
at something with david kelly that is um
that's pretty cool man that's yeah
absolutely you know that is
i mean you want to talk about it you i
mean you went down his some of his list
right there he's
he's a television god that guy pretty
much
you know yeah and amazing how he still
like he still writes the scripts himself
i mean he's got
i imagine a writer's room if he needs to
lean on it but the guy takes a majority
and he cranks out these scripts at his
age and after being in this business as
long as he has
right and there's such high quality you
know there's no burnout
obvious with this man you know he's
still bringing the heat
and that's again big sky that premieres
tonight 10 eastern on
on abc all right man look i i i didn't
mean to
you know say you know have you at hello
with some shots fired but
it's all up you know what i mean i just
figured i figured that would be a great
way to start things off
three five and one is not what you
wanted oh are you kidding me
but um but i mean you gotta see
you gotta you gotta like what you see in
the rest of the division
yeah yeah that's true and at least it's
true and at least it's better than the
dallas cowboys right i mean deep down
that's that's also what's the most
important thing right
yeah beat dallas forever yeah brian i
appreciate the call man
uh great catching up with you let's do
this again soon let's do this again when
the eagles are hosting the bucks in the
playoffs first round how does that sound
there we go there we go
you know we'll do that you take care of
yourself yeah we'll do
it you take care of yourself that's ryan
phillippe you got it uh
follow him on uh on twitter and
instagram at those addresses and big
skies tonight
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here